I've often been drawn to writing about
sex I've tried to answer this question
before i did in some interview recently
i do a lot of these written interviews I
almost would like to collect them you
know I do these email interviews and I
sometimes put a lot of effort into them
but I think sex is always obviously very
fascinating and is this little theater
where all sorts of issues and problems
can express themselves between two
people or in one person and so as as an
arena to like explore character that's
why I like a character's troubles or
heart or perversions are not perversions
but inclinations that's why I'm drawn to
writing about sex not so much for you
know the physical act and you know
though it's not bad to titillate people
also though two are like because a lot
of times people read books and they love
the sex parts you know oh that's what
it's like for me to be in bed especially
if you're honest about it about how
difficult it might be or how insecure
one might be or the thinking one has
while making love and you know so it's
one more area to connect to the reader
and to make them feel less alone as well
as like I said exploring what really
makes a person a person and a lot of
times that's most expressed in their
sexuality
I've never personally used craigslist
for anything but at one time I used to
love to read all the ads where people
wanted to meet people you know and I
mean all the variety you know Henry
James's brother was William James wrote
this book the varieties of religious
experience or something like that well
craigslist was the varieties of sexual
experience I mean I would read these ads
and someone be like I live in Ohio and I
want to come to New York and be
transformed into a woman and be your
maid and it was so plaintive and a lot
of times very well written and you know
or someone else specifically wanted this
kind of sexual act or or someone else
just wanted to be in love and it was all
these narratives I was just kind of
drawn to this mad chorus on craigslist
of need but i never knew part two of any
of the stories i wanted to write to the
people said did you meet someone or you
would read one at i want this you know
and then someone would write I want this
I'm like why don't they connect you know
they're each looking for the coefficient
you know don't they see that ad I hope
they hook up you know but so mostly for
me it was just a source of reading
material I've never actually used
craigslist to purchase anything or in
any way
you